hey James what do you say about creating
a display projects function that will
handle all of our projects and display
them on the page I have a better idea we
only just touched the surface of what
objects can do let's take a look at them
first and then we'll finish off our
resume using our newfound knowledge of
objects does that work for you yeah
why don't you start us off we saw
earlier that we define objects with
these curly braces and we also include
code for functions inside the curly
braces guess what functions are objects
what I know you knew that already it's a
little bit crazy but pretty much
everything in JavaScript is really an
object when you get right down to it
there's a link in the instructors notes
with implications from the relationship
between functions and objects for our
purposes it's useful to note that
objects can encapsulate functions as
well yeah for instance let's create
display as a method of the project's
object projects the object already
includes all of our data about all the
projects we've completed and now it's
going to include a function that will
help us display those projects using dot
notation here we can add a new property
to the projects object called display
and we'll set it equal to a function
within these curly braces we'll define
what the function display will do even
though we define the projects object
with object literal notation it doesn't
matter how we define the projects object
we can still create this property
display using dot notation this is
called encapsulation meaning that we're
holding the display function inside the
projects object it's a nice way to
organize our code into logical domains
and JavaScript makes it really easy to
do so nice so what should go inside
projects dot display mmm you know what
let's let the students decide first